my tiger likes ice cream any kind of ice
cream
that's vanilla ice cream and cooking
cream too whatever it was it
licked it licked it looked nothing hole
[ __ ] addictive
yeah it's sugar biggest drug in the
world mm-hmm
indeed yeah biggest rug in the world i
think the biggest narcotic in the world
is just cameras i think that beats sugar
what do you think i i you know
yes i think that it has been a downfall
yes i think it's been a doubt great
smart people
just couldn't stop loving himself too
much hmm
i see it because there's something not
natural about it it's not
it's not i'm slapping you like what well
we're supposed to have this conversation
yeah
but it's just supposed to be the three
of us hanging out we're not supposed to
document
and put it all over the world and then
someone's saying oh man caesar's right
somebody said that was cool and somebody
said yeah look he said i look good
through that
so i'm gonna do this thing i made me
look better it's good this is a drug man
i gotta go so caught up with this stuff
almost killed myself
can you imagine thinking tell me about
that just thinking i was somebody really
special
oh you know really really thinking
really special and
i had to have um what's that [ __ ] called
preferential
how do you say anything preferential
treatment that's the right word yeah
that worked i was
thinking i had to do that stuff man you
oh man you know i had to be beaten in
submission
you know when you there were submission
i had to be beaten in submission
i didn't give up that you know i'm hard
to give up i'm not a quitter that's
right
i'm not a quitter and man you had to tap
out
if i wanted to live in that world stay
in that world yeah
and tap out that's big right there you
learned some great lessons
but they were hard lessons yeah but i
rather learned something they never
learned them at all
yeah oh man [ __ ] life is beautiful i
never saw
it thought of it that way that's it
that's a drug
oh absolutely the biggest you have a
chance to see yourself the way you want
to see yourself
can you imagine that power to actually
see yourself the way your ego wants you
to be seen
can you imagine that power you can some
people can't even think you may start
thinking about it now
can you imagine to look like you want to
look in your mind and your heart and
your whole soul
to think that the whole world might love
you even
[Laughter]
everything that makes you excelled
imagine that all your flaws are just
everybody else's best day
i'll get you back to that and it and if
this does it to you
it gives the promise of immortality if
you're flawed is everybody else's best
day
exactly oh wow imagine thinking like
that
i never thought of it that way that's my
biggest lesson right now that's amazing
imagine but you've you've navigated this
and you've stayed true to yourself you
know it's not like you're a different
guy
than you were you know before you had
the show and after it's not you're the
same guy
no i just speak better in english and i
just explain things
clear okay but uh the the mexican guy
the hard-working guy the spiritual guy
the guy who loves his mom and his family
uh his country and and the opportunities
and the world and
and just changing the world that's still
the same way so that's why i never saw
it that way i saw it
as this is one way to help the world